your doctor will give you an epidural
Injection to reduce inflammation in your
spine reducing pain at allowing time for
your condition to heal the spine
consists of bony vertebrae stacked one
on the other shock-absorbing
intervertebral discs lying between the
vertebrae ligaments and muscles
connecting the bones and the spinal cord
with it's branching spinal nerves the
spinal cord is bathed in cerebrospinal
fluid and surrounded by a protective
membrane called the dura just outside
this membrane is the epidural space each
intervertebral disc consists of a tough
outer layer called the annulus fibrosus
and a spongy inner material called the
nucleus pulposus from aging or injury
the annual is fibrosis may weaken or
degenerate as a result the disc may
bulge into the surrounding neural and
vascular structures causing inflammation
and pain if the annulus completely
breaks down the nucleus may lose through
causing a disc herniation the resulting
inflammation and swelling may irritate
one of the spinal nerves nearby
resulting in a condition known as
radiculopathy disc herniation in the
lower or lumbar region of the back tend
to produce shooting pain down the leg a
condition known as sciatica if a disc
herniates in the neck the pain radiates
into the arm another condition that can
cause pain and inflammation in the area
of the spinal nerves is osteoarthritis
which may cause excess bone growth at
the joints of the spine resulting in
compression of the nearby spinal nerves
an epidural steroid injection is a
minimally invasive procedure to begin
your doctor will numb the skin on your
back with a local anaesthetic
using an x-ray image for guidance your
doctor will insert a needle between the
bones and through the ligaments of your
spine until it reaches the epidural
space at the level of the inflammation
once the needle has been inserted into
the epidural space your doctor will
inject the steroid solution
after your procedure you may apply ice
to the injection area for pain relief
and take over-the-counter pain
medications you may be able to resume
driving after 24 hours